il sait ce que pensent de barreaux il
pense que je peux parfaitement jouer
christine de suède ce lieu flatteur
pense aussi tu pourrais créer les
malheurs de sophie et doubler deux
orphelines
ça ne veut rien dire du tout marché en
attendant tu tout de même joué l'année
dernière encore en gala mais ils en ont
des lits et des fragments c'est pas mal
oui et je te la scène de pda et des
bandes de papier mais c'est vrai
j'oubliais et tu jouais pda
mais bon alors travaillons il doit bien
y avoir quelque chose de jouable là
dedans mais s'y ou un roger tous les
baigneurs auteur dramatique ne fissent
travaillera les parents jouerait ce
serait l'idéal
il est vrai qu'à 17 ans papa qui
demandait la principale arme chez lui
pas moi il est quoi partie du deal
seconde rangée dans l'aval du 11 mars
tu crois vraiment pas j étais mon dieu
tu es très sombre à tous qu'est-ce que
je jouais ton quand il est né tarit
curieusement tu ne jouais rien c'était
précisément combat moi où tu te trouves
dans une clinique une coïncidence je
suppose que merveilleusement béton
serbie